good morning everybody this is simple
simulators with generator co- routines
and pandas my name is James Powell we're
at P New York 2023 it is Wednesday
November 1st 2023 if you like this
presentation I give a lot of
presentations online in fact we have a
YouTube channel where we post all of
these feel free to I think like
subscribe or whatever people do on
YouTube if you want to see more of these
kinds of presentations if you don't
however feel free to also just give me
abuse in the comments on YouTube because
I think that's also what people do on
YouTube the goal of today's presentation
is to share with you some simple
approaches using nothing more than just
pandas and python for building a library
that can solve some interesting
financial problems our actual learning
goal here is not necessarily to build
these kind of libraries because even
though this is derived from real paid
work that we have done for the most part
this is probably not the majority of
what your work everyday tasks look like
instead our goal is to understand a
little bit more about the fundamental
tools that we use where do generator
code routines really show up in library
development and importantly how do you
actually write a library that ingests
and returns Panda's objects which I
think pretty much everybody seems to get
wrong anytime you see a function where
it takes a data frame and the data frame
has to have some specific name columns
there's something a miss and so let's
take a look the general motivating
example is we want to build a library
for portfolio construction some kind of
simulation so don't think high frequency
trading because if we were doing high
frequency trading it's almost certain
that we'd write this code in C++ or in
Java if we're going to write this code
in Python then we're going to assume
that performance may be important in so
far as we'll use pandas or numpy as
opposed to Pure python but where there
are certain bounds on the performance
that we need and so a realistic use case
for this would be something like mutual
fund construction where every day you
look at the market and you look at the
90-day returns and then you figure out
what comes in or what comes out of that
portfolio you do one trade you don't
really care about execution because you
don't handle the execution side at all
you just send it off to a broker and
this is a fairly reasonable and very
realistic example another example might
be something like this but for much much
lower frequency assets that you might
trade like fixed income assets where you
know you can think that a lot of those
may still be traded by human beings
getting on a phone and negoti getting a
price with another human being at that
scale we may discover that Python and
pandas have sufficient performance for
what we want that is to say we do care
about performance but there's an upper
bound to this so what we want is
moderate performance for back testing
portfolio construction over let's say
five years with a very simple strategy
that where we get that computation done
and say under a minute if of course we
wanted to do some kind of high frequency
tting or signal analysis then definitely
the approaches that we see here are not
appropriate however the tradeoff for the
slow speed that we get from using python
or for python being a major part of this
is that we will get some high generality
and so likely in that case where you're
doing some kind of like mutual fund
construction the strategy that you use
to construct a portfolio may be
arbitrarily complex it may not be as
simple as take these time series and do
some analysis as fast as you possibly
can and then do a buy or sell but it may
be a very complex analysis saying you
know we have some unequally weighted
portfolio and this is how the waiting is
is structured and we have entities drop
out when their market performance goes
under a certain metric under unless it's
under some other condition we need to
have a certain cash holding and we have
to deal with regulatory concerns and so
forth and so on of course when we talk
about things that are regulatory in
nature we do have unbounded complexity
because the only complexity the only
limits to the complexity of anything
that's regulatory in nature is the
creativity of lawmakers and their limits
for what they think is acceptable to
pass in
legislation one other important aspect
that we have here is and I think this is
a very important aspect that we don't
see in a lot of piece a lot of software
that's built on top of pandas which is
we want to be very much supporting what
you might call foreign data so you've
all used some tool that a cooworker has
written for some kind of analysis and
you just took a data frame that you read
in using a read CSV you passed it to the
function they gave you and it blew up
and your cooworker said oh no no this
thing can't have an index oh and the
columns have to be named this and this
column has to be this specific dtype and
you say well you know what this is not
really working with the data as I have
it it only works with the data that you
had when you designed this thing but if
you think about this kind of problem
it's very likely that an analyst is
going to have some data file that
they've pulled from some resource that
they're going to want to analyze and as
a consequence of that who knows what the
column names are who knows what the D
types are who knows what other index
level data there is and we want to be as
res we want to be as resilient or as
flexible to work with those structures
as possible finally we want to avoid
void certain esoteric things that we can
do in pandas there's one particular core
to this problem that is very tricky to
solve and we may be able to find some
esoteric mechanism subclassing python
built-in types or subclassing a panda
series or a data frame which by the way
is possible but I couldn't really give
you a sense of how much effort that
would be instead we're going to try and
make this reasonably easy for a user to
pick up and use subject to them of
course knowing some Basics what is a
generator Co routine what is index
alignment but beyond that what they can
learn online from any YouTube video on
our YouTube channel they can go ahead
with this and there's a couple of
questions that we'll answer about
generator Co routines pandas and so
forth and so on so let's start off by
thinking about how we'd represent
financial data well here if we're
building some kind of simulator like
this there's pretty much two types of
financial data that we want to be able
to represent the input data is going to
be some kind of Market data and the
output data is going to be the trades
that are constructed and a very naive
way for us to
represent some trades that are performed
is to represent them as a data frame
where in this data frame we have prices
so we bought something at $10 $20 and
$30 and we have volumes where we bought
100 units 200 units and 300 units and
maybe we have some indexing so here you
can see these are maybe just
Common Stocks that we can purchase and
in fact I've given a lot of
presentations where we use a structure
that looks more or less like this as the
core example the problem is that this is
a little bit phony baloney because in
truth this is redundantly encoding extra
data and in truth what we'll discover
when we try to build structures from a a
input set of panda data frames or Panda
series is that the larger the structure
that we give it the harder it is for us
to actually reduce the total number of
assumptions that we make and so even
though this seems like a reasonable way
for us to model this problem and it has
a certain amount of flexibility
associated with it for example if we
wanted to measure buys and sells we
could say well maybe the price is always
positive but the volume might be
negative and if we want to do simple
financial analysis here like What's the
total volume that we have we do a group
bu the
index grab the volume column and do a
sum here and you can see oh that's our
total Holdings in each one of these
names we could even do a uh weighted
average price and things like that a
weight average Buy price and sell price
and I've done a number of presentations
on just how you'd perform those comp and
what those tell us about pandas but one
of the problems here is if we end up
writing a
function that takes a data frame so for
example we'll have some function called
market value that takes a data frame
like this and it assumes that we have
particular column names we've already
violated that first constraint of
working with foreign data because who's
to say that the data frame that somebody
has given you that's a trace of executed
trades pulled from their broker that
you're then going to feed into your
system to do some sort of plotting or
some sort of analysis on has columns and
exactly those names and who's to say
that you don't have to do some
additional analysis on that for example
the prices may need to be adjusted to
take into account splits or other
corporate actions in that case of course
you might think that maybe that's that's
incumbent upon the user to actually
model themselves but it just really
feels really hokey when somebody says
this function requires a panda structure
that has this column with this dtype and
this column with this D type and it
feels hokey in the same way that if
somebody gave you a python function and
the python function said you have to
have trades and it's a list of a
dictionary of a list of a of a string
and a tupal and this has a string in
here the deeper and more complex this
thing gets the more you'd say hold on a
second how am I even going to know what
to pass in how am I even going to make
this reasonably General similarly
generally if we want to work with
foreign data we want to make it easy for
somebody to keep that foreign data on
the foreign data side consider this
circumstance when you're writing some
kind of Library code if we want to set
out a very Stark dichotomy we could say
you're either writing that Library code
where you are the most important thing
in the user's life in which case
anything goes you give them a crazy
signature you give them any structure
you want you're the most important thing
in their life they will abide by that or
on the other end you're the least
important thing in your life in which
case they will not countenance one
minute of having to restructure their
data to give that to you or what happens
very commonly in these in these
libraries is the original data structure
has some additional metadata associated
with it for example their original data
doesn't just have the ticker names but
it has the ticker names and maybe it has
some dates as well so this might be some
kind of
multi-index so here we'll do a
multi-index from arrays and we'll give
these a date range as well so here let's
do AE date range from January with three
periods and here of course we have to
give this as a list of two
entities and this is a very reasonable
thing that they may start off with and
that they may give you and you need to
make sure that you return that thing
right back out in the same way because
they don't want to have to say oh I gave
you these rows and you stripped off some
important metadata I have so now I have
to reassociate your output with the
thing that I with the thing that you
returned to me or with the thing that I
had to start with and it may not just be
two levels on the multi-index they may
have a portfolio maybe they have
multiple Traders and the original data
is Alice traded this Bob traded this
Charley traded this with this date and
with this ticker and so the greater
assumptions that you put on them the
harder it is for them to actually use
this tool and if you're not the most
important thing in their life they will
not countenance all of the Hoops that
you're making them jump through and so
if we really think about pandas what is
the simplest possible Panda structure
that we can operate on that's not a
pandas array because nobody actually
uses Panda arrays as first class
entities it's just a thing that you find
when you dig down into the tool it's a
panda series it's my belief that for the
most part any Library code that operates
on pandas probably should first and
foremost wherever Possible only ever
take as its inputs Panda series and
returns as its outputs Panda Series so
if we were to allow this structure I
would say that even though it seems a
little bit silly what we should actually
do is we should take the volumes and the
prices as to input datas and you'll say
that's strange we could just do the
single DF with two different columns
how's that different but here you're
forcing the user to extract that from
the data frame which is a zeroc cost
operation or effectively a zero cost
operation and you're not requiring that
they name this thing anything you are
however requiring that they keep some
sort of indexing here and unfortunately
I really think that if we're going to
talk about the signature of any sort of
computational unit that is built on top
of panda structures and returns Panda
structures what you really want is to
specify this is a panda series if
possible or a collection of panda series
The dtype I think is appropriate to say
these are numeric values or not and
whether they are capital I in 64s or
lowercase i in 64s maybe that doesn't
matter as much especially if you
exercise just a small amount of care
because as you all know you know a group
I unstack in a pivot table with a
capital I N64 D type may give you
slightly different operations depending
on whether you have that fast path where
it'll upcast into float 64 and down
downcast and you lose data or not and so
as a consequence I think what you can
reasonably assume is I'm taking a panda
series and that Panda Series has this
particular indexing and I think where
you can maybe get away with asserting
that there are certain names are names
of the levels of a multi-index and so
the way that I want to represent
financial data in this problem is very
slightly different than what we can see
here what I want to do is I want to
represent all financial information as
just a pendis series but how do we do
that because every trade has two parts
to it doesn't it it has what you bought
and how much you bought it for AAPL at
$300 a unit how do we represent that as
a panda series well consider one other
interesting aspect of this is when we
think about a panda structure we often
think about some entity that has like a
pus data frame an index down the rows
and some kind of indexing across the
column
but usually anytime we do anything
programmatic on a panda structure we're
always doing it programmatically down
the rows but structurally across the
columns in other words we have some
analysis says take this column by name
and then do a do sum or a do group by
operation down the rows and so one thing
that we see as a very common and
intuition for the use of pandas is that
for a panda series or for panas data
frame that is the columns are some kind
of structural entity and the rows are
some kind of data entity
well if we think about structural versus
data and that dichotomy there one other
thing that may might impinge upon us is
that anytime we have an unknown number
of entities that's always a data problem
never a structural problem that's why
for example if you have a CSV file and
you have three columns in row one and
five columns in row two and two columns
in row two in row three that's not CSV
CSV is always a strict number of columns
or each column means something because
it has a fixed structure well if you
think about it an actual trade may be
performed in the market is not
necessarily the price and the volume
this is assuming a two-leg trade where
for this two-leg trade I trade one set
of units of some asset and in exchange I
get some units of another asset where
that other asset is just a specially
marked asset a denomination of a
currency this is actually a two-l trade
this is 10 units of Apple equals
00 in fact what we can do is we can
devolve this financial data into a
series where you have have not two legs
specified but an arbitrary number of
legs specified with arbitrary grouping
within the index and you're just looking
at volumes and so for this same example
the way that I think we would represent
this if we wanted to build a library for
these purposes is we would represent it
like
this a series with every value and these
values would be let's do like this we'll
actually pre-compute these for you based
off
of whatever the prices
are and
here it would look something like that
now here this is going to be a little
bit silly but we'll we'll assume these
things settle in some weird way
so you'll bear with me the example and
of course we need
multi-index
and of course State
range and of course
capitalization it's always something
right now here what you can see is this
is a little bit phony baloney because
here you can see that maybe there's like
a three-day settlement period very
common in fixed income for bonds maybe a
little bit phony baloney for this
particular example but you can see
that's how it represented now
interestingly enough we can see one
interesting aspect of pandas what do
stack and unstack actually mean in
pandas melt and I don't think they mean
anything I think melt in pandas is what
happens when somebody accidentally puts
some things that are supposed to be in
the index in The Columns of an Excel
spreadsheet and you have to load it in
but I think stack and unstack actually
have real semantic meaning I think what
stack and unstack mean is you have some
data and whether or not that data is
considered homogeneous is subject to a
particular perspective is this
homogeneous data yes from a strict data
type perspective they're all in are all
floating Point numbers but is it
homogeneous data well can I sum up units
of Apple stock together with units of US
Dollars no that's meaningless and so as
a consequence what you can think is if
we want to do those easy sums we do them
either as a group by operation or as an
unstack operation on that first level
here let's um name our indices or levels
of indices so this is asset and
date there we go so we'd unstack the
asset
and then perform a sum and you can see
as a consequence of this we got another
calculation for free we now have not
only what our portfolio looks like but
what what our cash Holdings look like
which of course for the portfolio
construction analysis is a very useful
thing for us to know because we may be
limited based off of needing to retain a
certain amount of our cash holding in
order to you know keep the the strategy
alive or whatever whatever rules we have
here what you can see here is this is
this is a common thing the stack and
unstack are about taking some single
column of data and saying you know what
it looks like it's all the same thing
for one perspective for example they're
all trades that move the volume of some
particular asset and turn it into
multiple data sets that each have some
heterogeneous meaning oh actually we
can't add msft to AAPL to USD that's not
a meaningful thing to do so we have to
convert it back and forth now with that
said I think we end up with something
that's quite interesting which is we can
perform a lot of financial calculations
quite easily
but there's one detail to this that is
going to
be a bit a bit controversial are you
ready for it some of you look like
you're ready for anything some of you
have no idea what's going on so far I'm
not sure what you bought into here's the
thing I think fundamentally the whole
everything has a price and you multiply
times the volume and you get what it's
worth is total BS that's not how even in
an example like this anything actually
works I think especially since if you
consider the strategy construction the
strategy construction isn't is a is an
ahistorical thing it's it's
counterfactual you're saying given this
pricing information that I have for the
market how would I construct a portfolio
and how would that portfolio
perform but but I I didn't actually do
those trades it's not a real thing I
can't magically wish into existence a
trade that happened in the past instead
what I have to say is assuming under
these circumstances I performed these
trades and a limitation of that analysis
is if you trade in
ways which would have otherwise affected
the price your portfolio analysis is
going to be dodgy right like if you if
you sque if you short squeeze something
the prices that you're using
historically don't mean anything anymore
because that's not what the price
actually would be the price would be
affected by that in fact in general if
you think about it the price at which
you buy something is based off of more
factors than just one singular scal or
price cuz if I go to you and I say how
much is a peanut you'll say it's one
cent if I say how much is every single
peanut in the world well it's not one
cent per peanut anymore it's much more
expensive because somebody needs to have
their peanut butter and jelly sandwich
for breakfast and so yeah it's it's a
good breakfast and so as a consequence
what we actually want to have is some
mechanism that abstracts the the notion
that the market has the ability to price
things in some opaque fashion and within
that we may still make simple linear
assumptions for the purpose of this exam
but still allowing us to violate that
linearity or to add in some additional
complexity or for example to say if you
attempt to trade something where you
exceed the trading volume that we
historically see in our back testing
data we will not allow you to perform
that trade or if you do more than 10% of
that will not allow you do that trade
because then you would have affected the
market and the analysis is no longer
valid you can't have bought a million
units on a day where people only traded
100 units and still use the same pricing
data and assume that it'll mean anything
and so as a consequence what I think you
would want to do here is you need to
have an actual
class to represent the trading
environment and the reason for this is
when we talk about classes in Python
there's a lot of different things that
we might use these for for example we
often use classes in their simplest form
data classes or even what we can
construct with the name tupal just for
data structuring we have some
representation of some information and
we want to do the the dot and then the
name of what the thing is so for example
if represent a single trade in pure
python it's very common that if we were
to represent this in pure python we
might say you know what this is a trade
and it has an asset and a
volume and we'll just do it for data
structuring purposes because is a little
bit nicer than using a dictionary or
using a tupal the other reason why we
might use a class is if we want to
represent visually to a user that there
is some opaque entity here that has some
defined API the environment can do
something but we don't really know how
how it does something it encapsulates
that behavior and hides it from you and
also importantly for this example gives
you the ability to swap out the market
environment so what we can write is a
very very simple Market environment and
if you think about it a simple Market
environment should have the ability to
execute a trade now the naming here is
going to be really really hokey because
I can't come up with good names for
these pieces but if you think about it
if you start with the actual trades that
you have as a panda Series so let's say
and we actually need to represent it
like this 100 200 and
150 and we'll say this is Apple
Microsoft and
Apple and we'll make that a multi-index
in a
moment just so that we can represent
something akin to what we would actually
want to look at for this so here let's
make this a
multi-index with the date
range and we'll say that this is asset
and date
so we need a multi-index from
arrays and a date
range there we go and of course we need
this as well and here let's actually
format this code slightly
nicely there we go and you know what
honestly for these structures I usually
care more about the index than I care
about the data so just to make a point
of it I'll actually specify the index
who who creates Panda series specifying
the keyword arguments for the index
first this is a very strange
presentation anyway here's what we have
and of course we you want to name these
we always want to name layers of our
multi-index so this would be asset and
date so there we go so here we have and
also you know what if we're going to
name things we might as well name this
and this is a volume so there we go we
have our Panda series representing these
well I think we want the environment to
be able to execute these things which
means give us the other side of the
trade go out into the market tell tell
us what it would cost in order to
execute these and give us the other side
how many dollars we'd have to give or
receive in in order to actually execute
this and so what we could think is the
environment is going to have to have
some notion of its Market data now if
you think about the market data this is
one area where we might violate our be
open to foreign data assumption because
of course that's going to be so tied to
how the environment is going to operate
that we might need to put some
assumptions on it but largely if you
think about what the pricing looks like
for a very simple linear Market well
it's going to be pretty easy here let's
make a data
class and let's make this a data class
and let's just give it some prices which
would be a series indexed off of the
date and the asset as well as what the
observed price was in the market closed
price is a very common thing we get for
Yahoo finance or Google Finance which is
just about the level of sophistication
of the example that we're looking at so
far so we'll create an environment
and we'll give it some prices here and
we can take let's see how many days do
we have we have three days so here we
can do the following so let's say this
is trading at it's like $300 for one
$400 for the other 325 425 they all did
pretty good over this period of time and
we'll do a multi-index from
product with our
assets across we have three days don't
we so let's do this over three
days so these two stocks did very well
technology did very well over the period
of the analysis that we're looking at so
there we
go okay and finally let's name these
this is asset and date and so you can
see we do have some assumption that
we're imposing upon our user
specifically that their user
data is some kind of Panda series with
some kind of numerical
contents that is indexed identically to
the assumption that we have for what the
market looks like specifically something
like this and this should
be yeah that's good that's good the
names oh the names yeah thank
you so there we go so here's our trades
here's our environment and then we can
have the environment Go and execute
these and this actually ends up being
fairly straightforward to do now do note
that if we wanted to represent a
environment we wouldn't represent these
as singular prices and so we might bend
the rules very slightly in this case and
either represent this as the two sides
of the price obviously buying something
and selling something do not occur at
the same price we've all experienced
that when we go overseas we look at the
money exchanger and you're like hold on
a second you buy us doll I can never
understand which direction it is you buy
US dollars at 33.2 and you sell them and
whatever the case is don't worry they're
just ripping you off you know okay if
you get anything from this presentation
here's the thing you need to know if
there's a money changer inside the
security area of the airport and a money
changer outside the security the airport
never do it on the inside part because
they always rip you off like nobody's
business always go outside and they'll
give you a better price because they
know you're a captive audience they know
you don't know what's going on they know
you're you're desperate to get a cab
never do it on the inside Area same
thing with SIM
cards so here we might have a series or
we might simplify Our Lives slightly and
do a data frame where these are our buy
prices and our sell
prices and of course for this example
we'll create a very simple spread here
of just a fixed dollar so something like
this and so we can always buy higher
than we can sell otherwise we' be able
to make infinite money right
so we might represent those as some kind
of some kind of data frame structure but
you can think that these just two
similarly indexed structures from that
that we can then determine what the
actual executed price is and this
requires a little bit of panas mechanics
so rather than do it inside execute I'll
show you how I do this against just the
data frame itself it's a good
opportunity for us to practice some of
our pandas mechanics now what we know is
when we
have and let's create this with a none
here here we
go when we have structures that look
like this how do we actually figure
out what the executed price was anybody
know how to do this pandas off the top
of their head this is actually something
that turns out to be surprisingly slow
and the topic of performance hasn't come
up in too much depth with any of the
work that we've done so far we're kind
of assuming if we're using pandas and
we're doing aggregate operations at
pandas everything's at Panda speed which
is fast what I'm going to show you here
is relatively slow but in fact is not
really meaningfully slow in part because
if we were to build a system like this
these are aspects that we could easily
revisit after profiling and drop down
into syon or Numba or whatever other
tool we want into a raw into rust into a
c extension module whatever we want to
do unlike another problem we're going to
look at in just a moment well what we
want to do is we want to actually figure
out what the price is for each one of
these trades which is relatively
straightforward to do because we just
need to figure out what the direction of
these trades are so we'll take our
trades and we'll just get the sign of
these trades that'll give us whether
this thing is a positive or A negative
right and if it's a positive then it
means that bought it if it's a negative
that means that we sold it then what we
can do is we can take a series that's
indexed off of
these and we can do a do loock operation
on this so let's do a positive is a buy
a negative is a sell and we can do a
lock off the sign of our
trades so there we go we have buys and
sells so we know exactly whether these
are buys or cells or not right we can
just grab that we don't actually care
about the index anymore so we have that
layer we can take this result and we can
construct a multi-index from this so
what we'll do is we'll construct a
multi-index from the buys or the sells
from the
assets from the asset and let me see
what asset date okay so asset date and
buys and sells so now we have a
multi-index that Ma matches what we
actually want to do a look up on and
here all we have to do is we have to we
just stack that level now we're going to
name some things here so here we're
going to name one more piece here we're
going to do a set
Axis or rename
axis columns equals
Direction so we know the direction of
the trade and then that way we can give
this names asset date and
direction
like that so now we can perform a lookup
directly from this and then we can just
take our prices with the stack direction
or we could even pre-compute what the
stack Direction looks and do a do lock
here so that's the actual prices that
these were executed at once we know the
prices we can just take that result and
multiply that
times the actual trade volumes and
that's the USD we just have to reset the
AIS that's how many USD
that we executed these trades for now of
course we may have to adjust the date to
account for settlement periods or
whatever but it's a relatively
straightforward analysis note one
interesting aspect of this what if the
source data originally had extra index
layers because for example we're saying
there's this these books and these
portfolios and all of this other
structuring well it doesn't actually
matter because the code that we've
written is actually fairly transparent
so for example if we have multiple
portfolios so here we have Alice Bob and
Alice so Bob did one trade and Alice did
two
trades and of course oh know we need to
do this this is a from product so let's
do
uh let's do it like this
then we're gonna change this very
slightly we'll do two dates two and two
and that should give us uh we need two
more oh and by the way that's in the
wrong place too should be up here so
this is Alice and Bob and Alice
there we go and then of course here this
should be up
here so if we have that it'll just come
straight through on the other side see
we have it just come right through now
we might have to remove things like that
direction but we added that in through
that stack operation so that's not
really a big deal we know that it's
there so we could just drop that level
very easily because we explicitly added
that level so there is an assumption of
course that we don't have some duplicate
levels you don't have direct Direction
and we could do some tricks there for
example we could name this something
that they're not likely to name it that
way we can avoid overlaps with their
column names or with their index double
names but here let's take this result
and drop the direction level and what we
get out of this thing
is actually transparent to foreign data
if they had arbitrary numbers of
additional levels here the only thing
that we've done here that's maybe a bit
dodgy is we've reordered them
but note this analysis is going to be
expensive for two reasons one of them is
this lookup with the multi-index is
surprisingly slow when you actually
measure it I don't know why that is even
if they're if even if they're
lexicographically sorted it's still very
slow but if you think about it it's a
very simple operation to code up in a
little bit of C you're just scanning
through if these are sorted structures
to match for the exact entities and just
creating a new structure on the side and
so you could drop that part down into C
pretty easily or into Rost or whatever
you want quite easily so I'm not worried
about the slowness of that there's one
other aspect of this it's a little bit
slow we're making use of index alignment
to match up the two indices we have
assets and we have dates on both sides
of these structures we index align them
and get this result so we do the loock
in order to get uh properly index
structure however we know that this
structure is aligned already because we
did a Dot Lock to get the index in the
form that we want so this is maybe one
place where we could reliably
and
generally just do adopt values and when
we do adopt values we're going to lose
the we're going to lose the levels on
that so we'll do the dot values on the
other side so we'll do a
trades there and we'll do a DOT values
here and if we do the dot values there
we don't even need to drop the direction
axis at all or the direction level at
all and you can see we pass through
their their layers or their multi-index
exactly the way they gave them to us
without any additional mechanics this is
something that you you see you don't
really frequently see that there's some
difference between a times b and dbtimes
a as a consequence of the index
alignment and the reason for this is for
whatever reason pandas users seem to be
very shy to use index alignment for
anything they just reset index and they
do dot levels all dot values all over
the place but here I think is a
legitimate use of dot values to avoid a
spurious cost of an index alignment and
also to preserve the input data right
back or or certain aspects of the input
data right back out and so here you can
see we can execute these trades and a
very interesting consequence of this
approach is the total portfolio is now
just the
concat of these so if we take the
original
trades and just concat it against the
executed
values this gives us our full portfolio
now there's one more slight detail we
have to do here this result
has a wrong value for the asset because
it's telling us oh we bought apple and
then we sold Apple well one tiny detail
here and this is going to be a little
bit clumsy to do here on this result we
want to do a set axis and here's one
place where fundamentally we'll run into
some limitations of writing code using
pandas where that where it's Library
code which is unfortunately the Panda's
API despite being very coherent it has a
very clear mental model around index
alignment is very inconsistent in terms
of how it actually gives you mechanisms
methods to interact with that underlying
coherent model and as a consequence what
I want to do is I want to take all of
those asset values for the last three
and turn them to USD I want to change
the value of that I can do that with a
set axis call but I can't do that on
just one level I can drop a level I can
reorder a level I can swap a level and
just just let's remind ourselves of one
of the absurdities of pandas
because this is what I mean by the thing
being con coherent but not particularly
consistent if I have a data frame I can
swap
levels or swap
level I can
reorder underscore
levels why is there an underscore in one
of them and it's plural and there's no
underscore in the other one and it's
singular how how is that consistent in
any fashion but fundamentally it's a
coherent model it's all just operating
on the IND and doing some operations the
index it's just that the API is a little
bit all over the place here and
unfortunately if I can swap levels I can
reorder levels I can who wants to take a
bet here is it drop level or drop level
it's probably drop level but I bet you
you can pass multiple levels to it and
it works so this is a drop level but you
can actually drop multiple ones I bet I
don't know look at the documentation but
you can't add a level and you can't you
can't set a level and so there these
little bits and pieces that are missing
what do we do about that well one of the
answers is we go into the pandas code
and we help out the panis cor developers
by by implementing these missing
functionality and I think that is a very
worthwhile thing for us to do one thing
that we should recognize especially for
tools like Panda said they are tools
under active development they are not
complete there's still room for
improvement and there's still room for
ergonomics however if we're working on
this project for real we might have
something of a crisis here because we
have the right thing to do which is to
go and implement the missing operations
and we have the expedient thing to do
and the right thing to do may take an
unbounded amount of time we don't know
what it takes to get something approved
as a PR and DEP pandas and the
documentation requirements the testing
requirements and we have a user who
wants the system we're building right
here right now so I'm going to show you
something and this
is also very
controversial uh hopefully some of you
are aware of panda extension mechanisms
so if we go into
pandas we can go into Panda's API
extensions and we can register a series
accessor we can actually register data
frame accessors series accessors and
index accessors and in this particular
case I want to register an index
accessor but I'll show you a series
accessor the way this
works
is this is a decorator that operates on
some structure that gives you extra name
spaces under pandas data frame pandas
series or pandas index so for example
you ever wonder how you do like series.
DT to get the datetime operations orst
to get the string operations or cat to
get the categorical operations you can
add those yourself now one question is
whether or not we should have orientated
the entire library that we're writing in
terms of those so you have like a finin
for financial operations but I don't
think that's really what we want to do
we really want to preserve the the
generic meaning of the panda series as
just being operations on D typed values
not on business typed values but here
what we can do is we can do our own
namespace so let's do a namespace like
this let's make our lives Easier by
making this a data
class this thing gets an object which
will be a panda
series let's create a series for our
program and we'll create a very simple
series with one two three let's print
out this
series like that and by virtue of having
done this we now have our own
namespace now we need to register series
accessor data that's good that's good uh
oh and we have to get this a
name so it looks like EXT like that
there we go so now we have our own
namespace and you can put any arbitrary
operation so we can extend the
operations that are provided to us in
pandas this is I think a preferable
option on top over subclassing a panda
series or a panda data frame there are
genuinely packages out there that do
that geopandas as I understand
subclasses the panda series the panda
data frame between you and me I don't
actually know how much effort it is to
maintain that and another important
aspect of writing a library other than
are we the most important thing in our
users's life or we the least important
thing in our users life is how important
is this library to our lives do we
really want to subclass a Pan's data
frame and then have to watch Panda's
change logs for the rest of our life for
changes to the Pan's change logs that
them require that they make changes to
our subass entity probably not because
this is probably not the most important
project this is probably the project
that we do and then in terms of how it's
going so far we probably either leave or
are fired the next day and so our
ability to maintain this is quite
minimal instead what we might do is we
might look for the lightest mechanism to
extend this and so the registered
accessor just adds an extra name space
there with a very narrow struct a very
narrow mechanism for this so we don't
have to track changes to the underlying
data types we just leave this as just
regular old Panda series regular old
pandas data frames with extra accessors
now my view is if we do something like
this undor x we create something that's
very easy to search for in source code
and it may not be a bad idea even though
it's somewhat controversial for us to
identify what is missing or what is
inconsistent in the underlying Panda API
and to sand down those edges for our
users today while hopefully
simultaneously trying to up change these
change Upstream these changes by doing
something like this
so if this is a an index accessor
like
that of course this won't work anymore
this has to go on the index we might do
something like set
level and
here we'll take the name of the level
and the values and so
now we give ourselves a nice
place to put the missing mechanisms or
the or the things that we really wish
pandas had in a way where if this
actually does get upstreamed we can can
grip through our source code and look
for every underscore X or whatever we
want to name this so it really stands
out and remove this when panas actually
supports the thing that we want I think
this is a compromise and I think this is
relatively controversial but in practice
this may be the best option that we're
left with especially if we have a
looming deadline for the tool that we're
building and so here we might do
something like this now I'm going to do
this by hand just to show you how much
of a pain this is here I actually need
to not do a set axis but I have to do a
pipe another consistency in the Pan's
API is sometimes you can pass in lambdas
sometimes you can't and other times you
have to compose with a pipe so here
we'll do a pipe
operation and so that we can access the
existing index we'll do a set axis on
this thing we'll do a multi-index from
and this is so hokey from arrays
where we have to just repeat every value
of this so
asset and I think we have to get the
order of this right too so we probably
have to do this programmatically to make
sure that we get the order of this and
anything else that's in this thing right
but I'm going to hard code this for just
now so we really need to do this
programmatically otherwise it's not
correct and then for asset we just do
USD times Len
s and if we did that right there we go
and you can see and we got this wrong
with the levels of this thing
portfolio
asset date so here this is why we have
to do it programmatically because
otherwise we get this wrong but then
here you can see we've managed the
execution well one interesting thing
here is in addition to execution if we
want to actually find what's the market
value of our portfolio we write a very
similar method that just liquidates our
portfolio so liquidation of this
portfolio is very easy you just take
every asset that's not a currency and
you just negate it and then price it and
you're done and in fact almost all of
the operations we want to do in order to
get our market prices our unit prices
our Market values our p&l our positions
all of these are just going to be simple
group buys or constructing the other
side of the trade or the other leg of
the trade another interesting aspect of
this is how we construct this trade is
hidden behind this environment so we can
now break the Assumption of linearity
and if it's the case that we are in
Switzerland trading we cannot buy
certain assets with Swiss Franks if we
want to buy oil we have to buy oil if we
have to buy certain Commodities we have
to purchase them in things like Euro
dollars so if we happen to need to go
through some intermediary you take your
Swiss Franks and you turn them into
dollars and you turn those dollars into
oil we can also represent this very
easily with this structure a multile
trade for that what we might want to do
in order to get the grouping and the
attribution correct is put one more
level on our original
data just a simple range index with the
trade
identifier and
so
uh that's good that's
good and let's
see and then for here it's because we
lost the level here so here we got to
throw this back
in so here and this is why you have to
do this programmatically because
otherwise this is a real pain in the
butt but if we do this part
programmatically and now you can see we
can Group by the trade and we could
figure out you know what is our net
position for a given trade or we could
attribute our pnl or our market value
down to the trade level
and as long as we do this part correctly
and do it programmatically which is a
very small part that we're we're
simplifying for convenience right now
you can see that we can work very nicely
with foreign data and we get some
immediate consequences of this immediate
positive consequences of this it turns
out that most of the financial analyses
that we' want to do for this portfolio
are actually as simple as this construct
a unit portfolio just take all the
assets create a series with values of
one price it and that givs you unit
prices so you can do things like 30 days
return 60 days return all of that stuff
now
since we've got that problem mostly
solved I want to talk about an even
harder problem and this is a genuinely
hard problem that I do not have a good
answer for even up to including if we
had the ability to Upstream some changes
because I don't even know what the
changes would have to be in pandas to
support this often times when we talk
about pandas we talk about it as a tail
end analytical tool what does that mean
tail end analytical tool it means that
we've done some sort of work and at the
very end end of that work we come in
with our pandas code and we do some
analysis what does that Prelude what
does the work before the analysis look
like data collection is a big part of it
in general pandas is something where
we've done all the data collection all
the data is there it's in maybe some
other format CSV par it's in SQL we pull
it into our Panda structure and then we
do our analysis but we very rarely find
that we do a little bit of work in
pandas and then we create more data and
do a little bit more work in pandas and
create more data in fact if you really
think about it how often do you grow a
pandas data frame if you're using pandas
the way that many of the core developers
say you should you're probably treating
The Columns of a data frame as immutable
especially if you're using a jupyter
notebook and you don't even know you
know if you mutate a column you're not
sure run that sell once or twice did I
mutate it once is the right value you're
just adding extra columns onto the end
of the thing you're just growing the
thing or dropping columns or swapping
out columns but how often do you grow it
in terms of number of rows if you really
think about this anal is what we're
going to do in some core simulator Loop
is we're going to take some initial
trading balance we're going to do some
analysis on the market to say the top 40
performing names are this equally wait
and purchase those top 40 names and
we're going to end up with a panda data
frame with our trades that have 40 more
rows then we're do that again the next
month and the next month and the next
month and we're going to want to do this
financial analysis on the result we're
going to grow that pandas series over
time now does it make sense for the
strategy to want to look at the past
trades of course because if we've lost
an enormous amount of money so far maybe
the strategy should be aware of that and
tell us hold on a second something's
going wrong let's do something different
let's halt trading let's add in some
additional mechanism and that's a very
reasonable thing that a human being
would do because if you're getting on
the phone making these trades every day
and you see that your portfolio is doing
very poorly you're not going to just
continuously execute the exact same
strategy you're going to change it up so
it's something likely that you'd want to
encode in your strategy which means that
you're going to have a panas data a pan
series or panas data frame in this case
series that you're concatenating to
every Loop through your financial
simulator it is ex extraordinarily slow
to grow these structures in place and
the reason for that is if you think
about what pandas originally was built
on it was built on numai anday of course
now we have the arrow back end and there
are some options and arrow as I'll show
you that make certain parts of this
problem easier but what is a numpy in Dr
what is that foundational piece that
Panos was first developed on top of it
is a interpretive view of raw memory so
you have a memory address that starts
here some amount of data and you're
interpreting that with a dtype you're
interpreting that with a shape subject
to that there's some striding and some
size well how do you append to that
thing you have no idea what's sitting in
memory after that thing numpy and D
arrays and Panda series and data frames
have no notion of a capacity separate
from a size the size is the capacity
this is why you cannot append to the
thing without making a full copy and now
what you're thinking is in a loop for my
strategy simulator I'm going to identify
my strategies create new trades if I
append to a panda Series in a loop via
concat this will be so atrociously slow
you don't even know I'll show you some
examples of this because I have some
timings of this for another presentation
I
gave this if if you're still trying to
wrap your head around this this is very
similar to the problem that you have in
pure python where the python core
developers tell you you know what if you
want to take a string and you want to
concatenate a string do it with join
don't do it with plus equals
concatenation in a loop don't do it with
the sum function in fact there is a very
shallow error message that you'll hit
that'll say no don't do that you can
even comment that out it's like one line
to comment out let sum actually sum
strings but the reason for that is this
is the difference between the naive
approach and the dot joint approach it's
actually quite rare for us to see that
naive approaches are what is that uh 10
100,000 times slower than non- naive
approaches 3 seconds versus what is that
4,000 of a second this is what happens
when we try to do this with a python
string now if we try the same example
would say a nump and
Dray so what we'll do is we'll create a
bunch of numpy andd arrays we'll create
a thousand that are each a thousand in
size and we'll do a couple of different
operations we'll first H stack them over
and over so we'll H stack one then H
stack another then H stack another and
in each case we're going to reallocate
and recopy the memory so this is going
to use probably assuming that the memory
is actually freed and ignoring things
like like
fragmentation at least double the total
memory of the structure itself versus if
we construct a python list and do one
array operation at the end versus if we
use a builtin array from the python
standard library and a pen to the
built-in array and then turn that into a
numpy and d array and it's quite rare
for us to see examples where the python
standard Library actually beats the
pants off of numit seven times faster
appending to a nump and array via hstack
approach is atrociously slow this here
is the speed difference between doing
one array at the end versus doing them
peace Meal which is what you would have
to do in this example because we'd have
to get one trading analysis then another
trading analysis another one we have to
do it day by day or whatever date we're
rebalancing and Discerning our trades on
and so what are we going to do we can't
grow this thing in space we can try the
exact same example in pandas we'll
create a bunch of pandas series we'll
give them a very simple datetime index
and we'll try a one at a time concat
we'll try a pending to a list and then a
concat at the end we'll even put them
into a dictionary and then perform a
series construction from that
dictionary and we'll concat them one at
a time and we'll see just con catting
Panda series growing a panda Series in
place is very very very slow and it will
destroy the performance of this project
entirely this is why we're at a
Crossroads here because on the one hand
panas is a Tail anical tool so building
a library that creates new rows for an
existing series or data frame if it does
that in a tight Loop which is
necessarily the case for our simulator
we're going to have terrible performance
but we are only using panas in the first
place to get good performance in fact we
may discover that as a consequence of
the atrocious speed of growing these
things because the only way we can do it
is to make a full copy over with the
extra values every single time we might
have been better off using pure python
but here's the problem we cannot solve
this problem with pure python because
then we have to recreate all of group by
do you really want to sit there and
Implement Group by Sum that you get on a
panda series or data frame in pure
python do you really want to implement
like pivot table on a on a a list of
python tupal of course not so we're at
an impass here because we want to use
pandas not only for the speed but also
the convenience of the API and how
nicely it Maps these financial problems
especially the financial analysis
problems but also we want to grow the in
space now I'll go through the remainder
of these details fairly quickly but you
can see Arrow actually provides us with
something of a solution for this now
unfortunately the solution is not
available via pandas but we can do
something very similar Arrow has the
idea of an array being formed out of
many different record batches and
providing you a contiguous view or
something that looks like a contiguous
view of one array where it's actually
multiple batches that have been read in
because what is the premise of arrow in
the first place it's that if we want to
move data between different systems we
are paying an enormous amount of cost to
move that data because we're copying
things so how can we create a data
structure that avoids copies at all cost
well if you think about it if you're
loading data it's very common that you
might load data from this CSV file and
load data from this CSV file and load
data from this CSV file and arrow again
is going to say you know what you're
probably wasting a lot of time doing
those three loads and then copying them
into one structure so instead I'll give
you something that's kind of
like I don't know it's like a there's a
there's a term for this not there's a
there's a link list variant where you
have individual streams of that link
list and you link together larger
portions of it but this is basically
what the record batch is and so what piy
Arrow gives you is a chunk array an
array that can be broken down into Parts
where it looks like it's contiguous but
it's actually chunks we don't have the
ability to use this from pandas if we
did then we could have a panda series
that you could seamlessly append to
because you just pend a new chunk every
time and if you think about the nature
of this analysis what you're probably
doing is you're probably doing monthly
rebalancing so a couple of days of
Performing the trades every month in
large batches over just few total
batches how many total days are there in
10 years
3,6
52 or three depending on if you caught
well hold on is it necessarily two
because leap years are every four years
so you can never catch more than two
leap years in a in a 10e back that's for
you to figure out anyway we could do
something like that and we actually will
get much greater performance we'll get
closer to the pure python performance
because we're not making these copies so
what we're going to do instead is
something that is a little bit
weird when we perform the analyses on
our Panda series we're not going to set
our API to operate on a pandas series
because fundamentally we can't grow the
thing in place so we'll end up with
hotpots in our code where concatenations
are just going to be smeared all over
the place and the performance will be
terrible there'll be no way for us to
say oh drop this one piece down to see
it's everywhere the problem is
everywhere and fortunately we can't use
the arrow chunk array but we can do
something very similar if we're
Computing say the market value what if
we compute this off of the volumes
where this is a list python list of
series objects now we could subclass
lists we could subass Panda series or
data frame in order to give us the
ability to do something similar to the
chunk array I do not know how much
complexity would be to actually make
that work and I don't know how much work
it would be to keep that working over
multiple ver versions of pandas and so
as an expedient Choice maybe what we're
going to do is we're going to keep
things very very simple if a user can
understand that some tool takes a series
as its input maybe they can understand
that some tool either takes a
series or a list of series and then here
you do something like you know if is
instance volumes iterable or actually if
it's a series object then you do
something like
this and this is quite reliable and not
particularly ambiguous so you give them
a little bit of convenience around here
and then you force everything to operate
on lists of panda series that way in the
core of your simulator you can just
append to this structure and then
separately external from this code you
can
then ex with whatever experience you
need perform concats in order to
collapse this because obviously anytime
you're doing an aggregate analysis
you're not have to do that aggregate
analysis on the concat result if it
needs all of them or on each individual
component well for the most part things
like execute and price don't need to
concat the thing ahead of time and just
do an execute execute execute down each
one of these Series so the only time you
have to concat is really on the user
side when they want to do the financial
analysis they want to see what's my
market value what's my position or
whatever or what's my average price or
whatnot any aggregate that needs to see
all of them but what you could then do
is you could sprinkle in those concats
to reconsolidate these things on the
user end where they see their
performance problems and not put it in
the library this leads to a fairly
clumsy library because now everything
has to work on lists of series which is
a very odd data type I don't think
you've probably ever seen a function
that works on a list of panda series but
if you think the arrow analogy this is
basically the idea of doing a chunk
array but we're just doing it much more
clumsy at the pure python level
fundamentally however we can actually
get this to work and I think we can
slide this by a user for the most part
because obviously if we do just a little
bit to sand down the edges of this they
won't they maybe won't notice that so
this brings us to the last portion of
what we have I want to represent a
simulation with a strategy so how do I
represent the simulation strategy I know
I can do the financial analysis I know
those will be using only as their entity
that environment which will probably be
a data frame or a series and generate as
its consequence a series with just the
volumes with the executed side with all
the legs of the trade how do I actually
model the rest of this how do I give you
the ability to model a
strategy well there's one interesting
design consideration here and you'll see
this as we come up generally the one
feature that like I was looking at the
pytorch documentation the other day this
is this shocks me if you really want to
see a lot of python code written by
people who don't seem to really know
python look at the py TCH documentation
I don't know if that's controversial to
say maybe it is maybe it isn't but it's
like you'll read that and you're like
folks this is a decorator what are you
doing like in Reinventing decorators in
the pytorch tutorial it blows my mind
and one of the ones that I see all the
time in that documentation is does
nobody know what a generator
is if you're training a model and one
important aspect of that means you need
to return to the python level and in the
python level you need to decide if you
keep going or not because for for
example your training has hit some
Metric for you know the the correctness
of the predictions that it makes and
there's python code that's determining
whether you keep going or not that is
not a keyword argument it is a generator
or a generator code routine and in fact
pretty much any problem that we look at
that we would call an agent model or a
simulator or a back tester where and
this is an important qualification where
there necessarily must be work done in
the python level either because there is
no closed form solution for this or
because we need the generality of pure
python in order to implement some aspect
of the simulator the back tester this
should always be modeled as a generator
Coe routine and I'll show you why in
general if we think about what our
simulator would look like it's actually
a fairly straightforward
entity if we want the simplest possible
thing we can do what we'll do is we'll
model the
simulator as
a co- routine so this thing will Loop
forever each step coming into this thing
will take in some external data maybe
whatever the updated environment is so
that we don't have to pre-create the
entire historical environment but we can
kind of load those in P Meal we don't
have to pass this in as a an argument
here and one note that we can see is
when we look at the design of generator
code routines in Python it's very common
that whereas in a python function your
data are usually positional arguments
and your modalities are usually keyword
only arguments
but in a co- routine usually the keyword
arguments or sorry the arguments to the
co- routine itself are modalities and
any actual data is passed in via the
send mechanism and so I think the
environment is data it's not some
modality for this that would be some
kind of other modification on how we use
the environment so we'll do something
like this and on the other
side we'll yield out we actually want to
yield out the state so this is pretty
much what a simulator looks like you get
in some information that gets fed into
the simulator and you yield out what the
state is and if this is an agent model
here some kind of strategy
simulator then the
strategy is also an infrastructure like
this and what we have is something like
this so here we'll ask the strategy
actually we need to send into the
strategy the
environment
and the state is some function of the
desired actions and the previous
state so if we think about this the
structure is quite straightforward we
have a simulator that represents the the
loop every day or every unit of time we
give it some additional information what
the market environment looks like that
gets passed into the strategy entity and
the strategy entity says okay I get some
Market environments maybe if we think
about this you probably also want to
know what the previous state is so I get
the market environment and I get to see
what my portfolio looks like at some
point in time and I yield out what I
want to do the simulator takes what you
want to do and then decides whether you
can do it or not and then should give
you some feedback and so these two
pieces together give you pretty much
everything that you need for example if
you said I want to trade into a new name
in my index but the actual historical
Market data shows that was not enough
trading volume for you to perform that
trade entirely on that day or for
whatever reason your strategy needs to
break that down what you would do is you
would say okay take those desired
actions execute the parts of the trade
that you're allowed to execute given the
historical data kick back into the
strategy that it wasn't fully executed
and the strategy says oh I see that my
state is missing some volume if I want
some weighting of my portfolio and then
gives you the extra actions and
naturally you'll see then that strategy
will then split that execution over
multiple days now there could be some
small details to this for example what
is the time ticking is the time ticking
for this thing you pass in an
environment for each day and then you
get something back or is there like some
kind of intraday all of those are small
details for us to change because for
example we could do something like this
two Loops here and we could say
something
like let's do something like
this well I'll show you this for a
moment
so you can do all sorts of little
mechanisms there's one detail that we're
going to have to fix
here so something like
this and this should actually be a two
time Delta if we want to do it this
way so you might have two layers of
Loops here you might say okay I get in
an environment with a particular date
that's maybe the beginning of the month
when I do my rebalancing if you look at
Mutual funds and things like that they
do a lot of rebalancing on these monthly
boundaries or yearly boundaries so I I
pull in I give you my actions for that
rebalance and then there's an in Loop
that says okay these are all the all the
days in between and that's what I'm
trying to continue to execute to get to
my model portfolio what I want my
portfolio to look like and then here you
can imagine that this thing might also
Loop forever and then pass in that
information until here this might Loop
like this
until uh desired
actions is
none and then breaks out of this Loop so
we can we can model all sorts of small
details here very easily so maybe
something like that you know we Loop
forever where we put the timing here
we'll talk about in a moment we could
Loop forever and then indicate okay
we're done with all of our actions for
this particular day or we're done with
all of our actions and then trigger that
in in very simple ways with just one
line of code or small changes here now
when we think about this tool what we
might think about is at what point is
the end user actually going to write
code like are they going to write the
simulator and in fact in in our
experience with this we discovered that
the simulator itself is something that
you really need to know a little bit
more about co- routines to get this
thing to work in fact for example one of
the problems that we all know that
python generator Co routines have is if
I have a co- routine that looks like
this that takes some input value and I
create an instance of this thing
and I send in whatever my market data is
I get an error because I can't send a
non-one value to a just started
generator or a just started generator
coein or a just started asynchronous
generator or or asynchronous task or
just started asynchronous co- routine
there's a modality here specifically
that the design of generator Co routines
in Python was such that you have to emit
a value before you can receive a value
and this creates a certain modality
there's necessarily an ordering to this
because is serialized you have to do one
first and the other next either emit
first or or
accept and the python core developer
said emit first accept second what this
means is we can always identify whether
we're at the beginning of a co- routine
whether we like it or not because we'll
error out if we're at the very first
step we can't do an a send we have to do
a next first but if you think about
these entities and here let's make this
a infinite
Loop so we can do whatever we want after
this precious First
Step but this first step is special but
if you think about a simulator or an
agent model usually there's not really a
modality on the very first step if you
think about a game however there often
is think about this you're playing
something like hearts or Spades with
your friend and if you ever played a
game like that one of these matching
games where you have to play cards on
the table there is a distinction between
the very first person who goes and every
person who goes after every person who
goes after just tries to match whatever
they see on the table or exceeded or if
you're playing Uno you have to match the
color or the whatever of the card every
other person but the very first person
does something different they flip over
a card of the deck they play any random
card from their hand they're they have a
visible modality for where they're first
there's a different thing that you do if
you're first than if you're not first
but with those exceptions for the most
part things like these trading
simulators or many agent models there
really is no difference between if
you're at the very beginning or if
you're somewhere in the middle there may
be a difference if you're at the very
end but typically we model these things
as infinite sequence therefore there is
by definition no end this is why very
commonly when we see these structures
what we're going to do is we're going to
eliminate that first modality we're
going to invert the ordering here so
instead of first emitting and then
receiving we first receive and then Emit
and this is a very common little
decorator that you see that we
write so we just take this co- routine
we create
it and then we advance it one step what
people often call
pumping and just to make this moderately
complete we do something like
this there we go and now we have
something where we can no longer observe
that first modality the thing always
accepts a value first and then allows
you to do whatever you want and this is
likely what we want to use for any kind
of simulator where unless the nature of
the problem says there's something
different about the first actor which
again in many games the first actor has
a different set of choices than
everybody
subsequently unless that's the case this
inversion is going to be important
and to make this a little bit easier for
users we might do something like this so
here this could be something like
strategy
equals and then we just tell them here's
a decorator and they don't know any
different you just say okay here's a
decoror Ator called strategy put it on
top of all your strategies and
everything just works there's maybe one
other small detail typically when we do
these we have a dummy yield here so this
is the first input that we take but this
is a dummy yield it doesn't yield
anything and these are each incremental
input and each incremental output that
we give and so here we invert this it's
very likely that we want to do something
like this for under under for our
simulator
itself so the way we'll make this look
is we'll do something like this we'll
call this pumped
and we'll call strategy is just here
we're really going to pull a fast one on
our users because they're going to think
this is something really important but
it's not it's just our pumping of our
thing and then of course we're just
going to use this again here even though
that's not a strategy and now we just
have to make some small modifications on
this so that for example we get the very
first environment and state but we yield
a dummy and then we yield whatever
actions we determine then get the new
environment in the state then yield any
actions we determine and get the new
environment State and and it's likely
that we'll have to do some composition
here unfortunately I gave a presentation
a while back about this but uh the
pumping problem is very difficult to do
on asynchronous entities for the most
part this problem doesn't really have
any exposure to the asynchronous
universe because if you think about it
the speed that you're going to get out
of this thing you you got to do the
analysis day by day by day you can't
parallelize that in F you can't do
tomorrow before you've computed today
because what tomorrow is going to be
based off is what happened today and so
as a consequence if you need to get
speed here likely what you're going to
do is use something like multiprocessing
and you're going toay out the analysis
you're going to do some kind of search
of your some hyperparameter search of
your strategy you're going to say oh my
strategy assumes that we always keep 10%
of our total balance in cash but what if
it's 15% or 20% that's three strategies
three processes you run them all at the
same time you're unlikely to implement
parts of the strategy in some sort of
concurrent mechanism because I don't see
how you do that there it's fundamental
that
tomorrow's operations are based on today
and so I I would doubt that unless
there's some some data loading that has
to happen here you'd see much
asynchronous work here and even though
you might see that asynchronous stuff
like if you needed to use you know htpx
for some data loading or aoql for some
data loading it's unlikely you would do
that instead very likely the actual
ordering of the steps of the simulation
are necessarily going to be serialized
and then everything else is just kind of
in it's asynchronous land but you're
still locked on each each step of the
simulator and to this more or less will
give you what you want the combination
of this to together with your business
model give you more or less what you
look like now I'll give you a little bit
of pseudo code to show you what this
would look like all
in at its core what is the strategy
going to look
like well the strategy is going to be
here a simple
strategy an environment and some
state that you get each step and then
you tell it what you want to do and what
you want to do is perform some trades
how do you want to perform those trades
well what you might do is you might ask
this environment which remember is an
opaque object for a unit
portfolio here this means that your
environment class needs to have a little
bit of a large API
here it needs to be able to tell you for
example what all the assets that are
tradable and you can think that the
strategy itself may not be able to know
that it may be the responsibility of the
market to tell you these are tradable
assets as of a given day so unit
portfolio would just give you a panda
series with all of the traded Assets in
unit quantities very simple entity
price gives you the ability to price
these things and so that's just that
multi-index do loock operation that
tells you what those prices are absent
the multiplication that you do so you
might have that
here you might have execute which
basically pric
by the way here this should be on some
volumes which
remember if we really want to do this
right we might do this return a list of
panda
Series so we might have
execute which again you can see this is
a little bit clumsy but there's really
no other option goes through each one of
these and yields out the corresponding
side of that trade if you give it AAPL
it tells you how many dollars were on
the other side of the trade and you
probably also
need something like liquidate because if
you want to figure out what the market
value what is the market value of
something it's what you would get if you
sold the entire thing today so that just
means take my Holdings or take every
single trade reverse it except for the
currency trades and price those so here
this is just reverse and price and this
is
just price and reset
asset and here of course
something like that so you have those
four pieces so it's it's a somewhat
large and somewhat asymmetric API but
it's still quite simple and covers a
number of different cases because you
can see here there's no linearity based
in this the unit portfolio is a unit
portfolio for the perspective of saying
well what is the Returns on something
which just whatever one unit generally
we' assume that it's whatever one unit
would be traded at today versus whatever
one unit would be traded at 90 days ago
and for those purposes we may assume
linearity uh and you know we take a unit
portfolio we could price the unit
portfolio obviously we'd have some
modalities
for doing this some days in the past so
here we'd be able to price the thing
today versus some days in the past you
divide
that and subtract one and these are your
returns and again this is actually
fairly straightforward Panda's work
you're just pricing things you're just
constructing Panda series everything's
just operating on Panda series and you
get your returns here the one kind of
clumsy thing here is that this division
won't work because remember we return
list of panda Series so we lose some of
those operations so what that probably
means is we'll need to extend certain
parts of our API in ways we might not
otherwise want to instead of making this
price on one date we might
instead give us the ability to price on
multiple
dates and return one list
of panda series with an extra index
level or that in the date index and then
do a group by here and so here this
might actually need to be written as a
group by date and then an unstack of or
here an unstack of the date and then a
division and then here we you know
divide uh I don't think we can do that I
think we have to
do you know s whatever divided by y s
whatever minus one so here we might need
to do that just to make this a little
bit more convenient so we we end up with
somewhat strange structures and of
course the other thing we have to do
here is that pipe won't work so we'll
have to do the concat here just in case
just to collapse these so we'll have to
do a concat there I think that's a
little bit better than the other concats
that we need so this means that the API
is going to be a little bit richer than
we want it to be it can't be as
incremental because in some places just
moving between the series and the list
of series is just so clumsy that we we
need to add an extra keyword arguments
to handle that internally but there we
have returns based on these returns we
can figure out what are waiting of our
portfolios these are the things that we
want you know if we want the N largest
20 this is the top 20 returns and then
we just take whatever our state is which
whatever our portfolio is maybe this
needs to be conc
added and we could you know compute the
market value of this which does not need
to belong anywhere except at our levels
so we could have a convenience level
that does not need to be part of the
core Library level for doing some things
like that market value
computation and so we can keep that very
shallow and very presumptuous about what
the data looks like because it'll sit
really close to where the foreign data
looks like and then you know take this
and then figure out how to divide that
by the the number of entities we have to
get what the model portfolio looks like
and then execute those actions and for
the most part you can see even though
this is a pseudo code it actually gives
us an enormous amount of generality
despite some of the areas where we just
run into limits with how we can use
pandas we can for example arbitrarily
decide what we want to trade into
arbitrarily decide how we want to
compute that using just regular Panet
mechanics just that one tiny unfortunate
consequence of sometimes you need to do
a concat in order to get that to work
properly or we have to put a four loop
on top of this thing and for the most
part if we actually measure the speed of
this because I built a system like this
we discover that except for small
hotspots
like uh the multi-index lookup being
slow which we can drop down to syon the
performance of this will actually be
moderately good in my tests for Sim
system looks like this we're able to
process a million trades off of 10
million sorry off of a thousand unit
sorry think it's 100 million rows of
pricing data against a million rows of
trading data we're able to do all the
financial analyses in like two or three
seconds which is about the same speed as
the read pickle operation so there's
still room to get that down to under a
second but still for what we're looking
at here that's pretty realistic maybe 10
a 10-year portfolio analysis with some
kind of strategy and we run into certain
problems you can see that building a
library on top of pandas is not as easy
as you think there's actually a lot of
very small fine details that we have to
worry about in terms of how this is
going to be used and in terms of how we
structure the inputs and the outputs to
make this feasible I discovered in this
that I thought I write a function that
takes anan's data frame you know F input
is DF return a DF assume the columns
name something but all all of those
assumptions melt away and you actually
need a very delicate hand in order to do
this properly one thing that sadly I
have not really seen in any code that
uses any code except maybe very popular
libraries that accept Panda data frames
and even then some of the plotting
libraries that take Panda's data frames
in some of the machine learning
libraries like Pan's data frames as
input they're very presumptuous about
what these things look like what the
shape of these things are and I don't
think they need to be that way I think
there are actually approaches which is a
little bit of delicateness for you to
solve this and so with that said thank
you all for joining us for this
presentation this has been simple
simulators with generator coou and
pandas I'm James pal thank you everybody
and I hope you
[Applause]
enjoyed